foreign CEO and founder of the center
for American Liberty she joins us
tonight Army thanks so much for coming
on so tell us what this suit alleges
well as you mentioned Tucker Taylor
Lorenz notorious cry bully who's jumped
around from various Publications and is
now at the Washington Post has made her
career out of clout chasing and
increasing her stature by picking
victims who happen to be on the upswing
in the public eye and attacking them
viciously first of all trying to saddle
up to them making friends with them and
then ultimately uh you know gutting them
like a fish and then using that for
material for her pieces and along the
way violating all kinds of ethical rules
and journalism so in this case she
focused on our client Arianne Jacob who
was running
influencer houses and and managing
Talent on Tick Tock you know believe it
or not it's a huge industry worth
billions of dollars and and our client
was on the upswing there so giving five
hours to respond to her hit piece
questions in writing which is her Mo and
the mo of other dishonest journalists
she was provided with information
debunking uh many of the lies that she
published in her story and having
written information in hand debunking
these lies she went ahead and published
anyway and Then followed up on that with
posts on social media lying about our
client lying about our clients business
practices specific conduct the way these
houses were set up and and Safety and
Security around them calling our client
a bad actor on social media and
basically destroying our clients career
and causing her damage in the tune of
millions of dollars now this isn't the
first time Taylor Lorenz has done this
she's also gone on to proceed to try to
destroy Libs of tick tock also a client
of my law firm and has even beefed with
her co-workers at the New York Times
last week at the Washington Post and
other journalists at NBC so this lady is
a one-woman wrecking crew and I'm hoping
that we will finally be the ones to hold
her accountable for all the damage she's
caused to so many different people
Tucker well she's certainly a bully who
I think needs to be restrained and I and
I'm appreciate your telling us about
this hermit Dylan
great to see you thank you subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube channel to catch
our nightly opens stories that are
changing the world and changing your
life from Tucker Carlson tonight